best-selling author jacqueline woodson
has written more than 30 books for young
readers including more than a dozen
picture books for children she's also a
winner of the national book award and a
recipient of the macarthur so-called
genius grant her new book the year we
learn to fly is about two kids who
discover how to use their minds to lift
themselves out of challenging situations
here read by yours truly is an excerpt
that was the autumn our rooms felt too
big and lonely with only us and them and
the darkness coming on so fast but while
we hugged ourselves against the too
quiet of it all we remembered that we
didn't have to be stuck anywhere anymore
my grandmother had learned to fly from
the people who came before they were
aunts and uncles and cousins who were
brought here on huge ships
their wrists and ankles cuffed an iron
but my grandmother said nobody can ever
cuff your beautiful and brilliant mind
so our people learned to fly she said
they dreamed a thing and made it happen
closed their eyes and flew away home
lift your arms my grandmother said close
your eyes and remember somebody
somewhere at some point had to figure
out they
could fly
and we're happy to say jacqueline
woodson joins us now jacqueline good
morning exactly wait jacqueline before
you say anything what did you think
about tony's read of your words teddy's
a big fan
what'd you think
i loved it i loved it i did i love the
writing of it
yes yes yes well the rhythm of it is
easy to get into because it's a
beautiful book and the concept is also
gorgeous this idea that children can use
their imaginations to lift themselves
out of very difficult situations it's
incredibly timely right now so many kids
are at home and parents are at home
because of the pandemic but you actually
started way before the pandemic do i
have that right
yes i did
you're right what gave you the idea i
started writing it
i you know
kids have always had to struggle in some
way shape or form and that idea of being
stuck inside a moment a place a physical
space and not having the freedom to
leave that was one that i always thought
of you know as for myself as a kid and
as an adult raising children so and then
the pandemic came along and it's like
wow this is so much bigger than what i
was thinking of
jacqueline i love that you made a
reference to the ancestors because i've
never seen that in a children's book
what made you think that that would work
in this particular context at this
particular time and what you said about
imagination too
i think that our ancestors are always
with us and it's the fact that we're
here you know that i'm here talking to
you all is about the ancestors having
survived something to get us to this
moment um and i i feel like
life is a continuum like we move on we
move to the next place and
and the way we stay remembered is by
people talking about us and and so the
ancestors are the people who got me
jacqueline woodson to this moment um and
they're important and and they survive
so the fact that they survived wars they
survived enslavement they survived
pilgrims they survived you know so much
to get us as human beings to 2022
is important to remember
and jacqueline you mentioned enslavement
and you write very descriptively about
slavery why do you feel like it was
important to write about it in that way
in a kid's book
one thing
one thing i really loved about that
spread is the fact that
against
talking about a really painful time in
our history which is the truth and i
think it is really important to bring
the truth to literature there's the
juxtaposition of rafael lopez's
beautiful illustrations to to sh
so we can get the truth and we can get
the beauty at the same time so it's not
giving young people that just the pain
of a moment because the truth of it is
in every painful moment there was also
some kind of healing some kind of beauty
something that helped us get through
that moment and i think a lot of times
when we talk about enslavement when we
talk about history
specifically african american history to
young people if we don't
know how to do it right we talk about it
from a very painful place and i and we
have to talk about the survival element
of it and that survival element of it
had to be about having a ferocity having
beauty having hope
inside of that pain
did jacqueline when you wrote that
passage which is unusually blunt for a
kid's book it's also specific it it's
their ancestors right the the narrator's
ancestors and that's not the story for
all people did you have an editor or an
early reader say hey jaclyn maybe soften
this broaden it out we want everyone to
feel their viewed in this book or was
that not a calculation that came to you
it is a story for all people it's it's
our story for everybody
right so it is the story of enslavement
is not just about black folks you know
so and i think that's important to know
and it is a story so fortunately my
editor nancy paulson didn't say make
this softer i've because i've written so
much for young people i know that young
people can handle the truth and they and
they don't look at it as this you know
terrifying and terrible thing they look
at it like whoa yeah this did happen i
want to know more about it
and i'm open to hearing it
the other thing that's interesting that
i found is that parents make assumptions
about what they think their own children
will connect to in a book and it's not
always the same thing that the kid
imaginably is able to connect with so
the specificity is not an issue
jacqueline woodson we have to go nate's
holding up the book it's a great one
pick it up it's called the year we learn
to fly available today wherever you are
we'll be right back
bye jacqueline hi jacqueline